[Musique]
avant toute chose
je suis convaincu d'une chose
aujourd'hui on vit des crises
écologiques économiques sociales mais
moi au plus profond de moi même je crois
qu'on vit une crise du cosmopolitisme ça
veut dire quoi cosmopolitisme le cosmos
le monde politis le citoyen moi je crois
qu'on crée une vraie une véritable crise
de l'édit de la citoyenneté mondiale
paraîtra conceptual comme ça ça ne l'est
pas tant que ça moi je suis persuadé que
si on arrive à se connecter à notre
sentiment d'appartenance animalité
commune alors ne sont tous ensemble
capable de répondre aux défis du 21e
siècle
ça vous paraît fou
peut-être
mais je vais essayer de vous emmener à
travers mon histoire sur comment on peut
être on peut essayer de résoudre ces
choses là pour cela je vais avoir besoin
de vous
que vous me suis vieille et je vais vous
demander s'il vous plaît de commencer
par fermer les yeux
vous inquiétez pas
je vais vous poser une petite série de
trois questions vous êtes prêts
est ce que vous seriez prêt à faire
confiance en l'inconnu comme moi
qu'elle est là hier personne à qui vous
avez fait confiance et à qui vous lui
avez extrêmement expressément dit
rappelez vous la dernière personne qui
vous a exprimé sa confiance
quel sentiment avez-vous ressenti
merci vous voyez ouvrir les yeux pour
regarder autour de vous
pour moi ces petites questions c'est
l'essentiel de notre vie sociale ça fait
appel à trois choses la confiance en soi
la confiance dans l'autre la confiance
dans les autres je suis persuadé qu'on
nous enlève réécrire notre pacte social
et qu'on doit aller vers cette chose-là
le pacte social doit être basée sur la
confiance en soi la confiance dans
l'autre la confiance dans les autre dans
les documents que vous avez reçus à mon
avis vous êtes passé du côté sombre de
la peur la peur à ce que je vais être à
la hauteur de cette confiance est ce que
je vais être en capacité de tenir la
confiance qu'on voit transmises est-ce
que je vais avoir la capacité d'exprimer
la confiance à l'autre et le côté clair
le côté de la joie hu il me fait
confiance ça veut dire que je suis à la
hauteur des choses
comme je vous le disais un peu en
accéléré par rapport à l'offre de base
en être venu pour moi c'est là bas de
notre pacte social c'est la confiance en
soi la confiance dans l'autre et la
confiance dans les autres
je m'appelle julien j'ai 42 ans
aujourd'hui je crois avoir confiance en
moi
j'ai une famille et monte c'est une
situation sociale très confortable et je
suis vraiment persuadé qu'ensemble on
peut répondre aux défis du 21e siècle
mais ça n'a pas toujours été le cas loin
de là
ça a été dur pour moi
mais j'ai réussi à changer les choses la
première chose c'est que j'avais eu des
étapes de compréhension la première
c'était ma capacité à comprendre qu'on
avait la faculté tous ici à montrer les
défauts des autres appuyer là où ça fait
mal très mal
et pour vous l'illustré je vais prendre
deux petits exemples
1 une personne bien connue
stein est l'hôte de moi
un jour albert einstein est au tableau
il écrit la table de 9 tout est parfait
sauf le 9 x 10 où elle écrit 9 x 10 cl
91 bien sûr vous vous dites pas possible
tout le monde se met à rigoler
comment est ce possible
il se retourne et il dit
malgré le fait que j'analyse n99 choses
bien vous n'avez regarder que mon défaut
vous avez aimé ça et vous en être moqué
est-ce que vous avez déjà ressenti ça au
travail
à la maison
dans votre vie quotidien un sentiment
pas très agréable on a l'impression
d'avoir bien fait mais on nous pointe
l'erreur
bon je vais pas rester sur albert
einstein parce que je le connais pas
bien je vais essayer de vous parler de
moi je le connais un peu mieux
imaginer le petit julien
né dans une famille en banlieue
parisienne avec deux frères famille
monte
imaginez maintenant que ce petit enfant
un handicap invisible
c'est plus le même ressenti que vous
avez de la peur car elle
est oui je suis
10-10 orthographique
sa gelée compris très gelé vécu très tôt
mais je l'ait compris très tard en effet
dès la maternelle dès que je suis rentré
dans le cadre scolaire de l'institution
j'ai compris que j'étais un petit peu
différent il y avait des choses que tu
es très difficile pour moi j'ai subi les
montres et des le frein dès le plus
jeune âge je ne tenais pas mon stylo
correctement du coup je colorier pas
bien
j'étais
gamin capacité de pouvoir apprendre les
chansons là et peu de mémoire vous voyez
pourquoi c'est un peu dur pour moi
mais aussi
il y avait plein de choses qui devenait
difficile et puis j'ai vécu avec sa sans
vraiment comprendre ce qui se passait au
fond de moi ski
c'était en train de s'ancrer en moins
mais petit à petit ma confiance à la bc
- les règles tout allait bien
et ça ça augmente et petit à petit
jusqu'au moment où vous avez un
cinquième on vous commencez à vous
demander à faire des rédactions
savez l'orthographe 7 normalement cet
outil qui sert veut passer d'une langue
orale à une langue écrite
cet outil qu'est aujourd'hui la norme de
la société qui fait que soit vous êtes
quelqu'un de bien parce que vous écrivez
bien soit vous faites des fautes et là
vous êtes quasiment sol en
bois en tant que 10 orthographique ça ça
a été très dur plus je suis monté dans
les classes plus ça a été violent pour
moi jusqu'à cette terrible phrase
monsieur masque vous n'êtes bon à rien
vous n'arriverez jamais à rien
waouh ça fait mal
devant toute la classe
ce professeur je pense pas que c'était
une mauvaise personne je pense qu'il
essayait de m'accompagner qu'il essayait
de me réveiller mais il n'a pas du tout
compris ce qu'ils jouaient il n'a pas du
tout il n'a pas du tout été ouverts à ce
qui se passait le par manque de temps
par manque de moyens je ne l'accablons
pas mais ça allait très très loin
jusqu'à ce moment-là je perds confiance
en moi déjà ce n'était pas un fort je
perds confiance dans l'institution celle
qui est censée nous encadraient super
confiance dans la société
je vais jusqu'à me
autodétruire
il aurait peut-être pu imaginer comme
d'autres l'ont fait plus tard monsieur
masque vous avez une voix si
particulière que vous devriez faire de
la radio
peut-être aussi que
on aurait pu le former aux troubles
cognitifs spécifiques
ces troubles qui font qu'on a du mal à
apprendre que nous apprentissages sont
difficiles qui ça joue sur le langage la
mémoire la capacité motrice avaient tous
ces personnes disent dyslexiques vous
voyez
ce n'est pas forcément un problème c'est
une singularité
mais quand elle n'est pas acceptée par
la norme ça en devient un problème est
la personne le subit et du coup va
jusqu'à cette démotivation
et trompe le disent ils ont vraiment des
répercussions sur soi mais aussi sur
notre interaction avec avec la société
aujourd'hui je vous le dis tout va mieux
et du coup je suis devant vous aussi
pour affirmer que je suis dyslexique
que je suis là devant vous pour vous
dire que il faut détecter les gens il
faut les accompagner allait les aider
dès le plus jeune âge car oui
l'accompagnement change tout
j'en suis persuadé je vais essayer de
vous le prouver
bien sûr j'ai des moins je voulais dit
jésus soto graphique mais c'est beaucoup
de plus et c'est plus les gens qu'ils
l'ont qui m'ont accompagné à les voir
pour aller remercier ici bien sûr ma
famille
ceux qui m'ont accompagné dans les
passions ceux qui m'ont montré qu'ils
avaient pas que l'institution et qu'à
côté de ça il avait des capacités autres
par
tous mes amis qui m'ont aidé à aller
jusqu'au bac
bien sûr mes professeurs parce qu'elle
avait beaucoup qui m'ont accompagné
différemment pour essayer de me prendre
avec ma singularité
mes collègues qui aujourd'hui me freine
comme je suis qui font qui je suis et
qui m'accepte comme je suis bien sûr ma
femme marciel depuis 15 ans elle
montrait m'aide à ne pas retrouver dans
mes travers
et puis même si celle qui à 40 ans a
posé des mots sur ce que je vivais
les 40 premières années de ma vie je le
ressentais je ne savais pas ce que je
vivais parce que à mon époque on a
détecté pas les choses
heureusement tous ces gens là et bien
d'autres vont accompagner sans le savoir
ou en sachant en tout cas et c'est là et
ça aller jusqu'à une phrase tu pourrais
pas dire merci à tout le monde mais je
vais vous en citer une
qui vient de quelqu'un qui pourrait être
vous une personne simple en bénévoles du
monde associatif
quelqu'un qui passait week-end sont des
terrains de foot a engagé les gens à se
développer a essayé de faire du
collectif avec les singularités des
personnes qui arrivent
cet homme il m'a simplement dit julien
après ce que tu viens de faire tu as en
toi une troupe force incroyable avec ce
que j'ai vu tu seras capable de faire
tout ce que tu veux
ouah
ça c'est vous
ça c'est le début de la reconstruction
bien sûr plein d'autres gens me l'avait
dit avant mais cette personne tierce qui
n'est pas ma famille qui n'est pas
méchant proximité qui ne l'affirment
alors là ça change tout
pierre malheureusement je lui ai jamais
dit
alors ce soir je préfère aussi le
rajouter dans la liste des gens à qui je
dois dire merci merci et merci à pierre
qui a été un de mes accompagnateurs de
vie
il ne sait pas il sait pas où je suis
mais j'espère qu'il entendra
à partir de ce moment là je me décide à
me dire ok il faut que je sache où sont
mes plus quels sont mes compétences et
que je me concentre là dessus
aujourd'hui devant vous et vu la
thématique je vais affirmé mais plus
je suis capable d'imaginer or la norme
je suis un innovateur sociale
j'ai une motivation à toute épreuve pour
remonter les courants contraires je sais
me battre dans les solutions dans les
moments difficiles
je sais mon tour et je sais que créer
collectivement
et surtout le plus fort de tous c'est
que de cette problématique aujourd'hui
je suis sûr que demain ensemble on peut
faire différemment que demain nous
pourrons construire un monde qui sera
égalitaire
mais est ce que tous les gens qui sont
disque on parle de 6 à 8% de personnes
aujourd'hui à ce qu'elles vont avoir ma
chance à ce qu'elles vont avoir les
mêmes personnes pour les accompagner ou
est-ce que elles vont subir cette
société de la méfiance de société de la
défiance
qui nous amène à perdre notre empathie
et potentiellement mener très rapidement
les gens sont des voies de garage
une vraie question
moi je crois qu'on peut faire
différemment il faut se donner les
moyens et je vous donnerai un petit défi
tout à l'heure peut-être
oui car moi j'ai fait un rêve
depuis 20 ans je rêve d'un monde dans
lequel chacun pour être cela la
singularité de chacun pour être affirmée
on pourrait avoir confiance les uns dans
les autres et surtout les termes qui
sont devant nos mairies liberté égalité
fraternité serait une vraie réalité pour
tous et pas simplement pour ceux qui
sont dans la norme
on est capable de faire ça vous allez me
dire vrai mais julien d'un utopiste
ouais c'est vrai et je suis hyper fier
de l'être
bernie tu puisses qui essaye de mettre
en pratique ses ces grandes ses grandes
idées depuis vingt ans j'ai créé un
mouvement d'éducation aujourd'hui je
dirige une ong éducative qui qui a 90
personnes qui salarient 90 personnes une
société quand une organisation éducative
qui accompagne les gens face à leurs
peurs qui leur permet d'exprimer leurs
peurs pour construire le monde de demain
une organisation qui crée des ponts
entre les personnes dépôt entre les
cultures pour montrer qu ensemble nous
pouvons faire ensemble nous pouvons
faire des belles choisi
une ong qui forcément utilise ballet
pédagogie active
celle qui après celles qui permettent
d'aller d'acquérir des savoirs des
savoir faire et des savoir être par des
méthodes différentes
qui sont pour moi les savoirs du citoyen
du monde de demain ce qu'on nous oublie
dans cette norme il faut qu'on les amène
par ça
alors
aujourd'hui malgré tout ce que je viens
de vous raconter
ce qu'ils sont dans l'innovation sociale
ce qui crée le monde de demain avec vous
tous on a envie de vous donner un
message
là besoin de vous
la quittez pas je vais pas vous demander
des sous
je vais vous proposer trois défis le
premier c'est simplement de vous dire à
502 vous voyez quelqu'un de singulier
vous avez l'impression de pas le
comprendre et une méthode très simple
faites le pas de côté clic poubelle les
regardait le par un autre axe déjà ça
changera beaucoup de choses pour lui le
deuxième est il à interpersonnelles
est-ce que nous serions capables de
donner un don de confiance en plus par
jour à nos amis et notre famille anneaux
à nos commerçants de proximité
et le dernier c'est sûrement le plus dur
que celui qui est en train de faire
devant vous c'est d'exprimer ses
faiblesses d'accès peut-être montré nos
limites si nous nous montrons pas nos
limites ne pourront pas coopérer si nous
n'acceptons pas la limite des uns et des
autres ne pourront pas construire avec
les limites de la planète nous avons
besoin d'être transparent sur qui nous
sommes pour pouvoir construire ensemble
la coopération commence là
pour finir merci pour votre écoute je
finirai par une phrase d'albert camus
être différent n'est ni une bonne ni une
mauvaise chose c'est simplement que vous
avez réussi à être vous même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]